The 1920s were a time when Wall Street didn't just trade stocks it traded souls.
Down in the bowels of the New York Financial District, the ticker tape machines hummed
like mechanical hearts, spitting out numbers in a relentless clack-clack, and those men
in their pinstripe suits, they weren't just watching prices, they were watching themselves.
This was the birth of numerical obsession.
The tape moved faster than thought, and the men who stared at it became its prisoners.
A single digit could make them gods or fools.
Up?
Genius.
Down.
A failure.
They were the first to understand what happens when you anchor your worth to something that
isn't you, something that changes on a whim, like the wind through a stock ticker.
And here's the thing.
We've all done it since.
Psychologists like Kahneman and Tversky gave it a name, anchoring.
The human mind latches on to the first number it sees, the first metric, the first standard,
and builds its entire world around it.
Your bank balance.
Your follower count.
Your weight.
Your likes.
Pick one.
Anyone.
And suddenly, your life isn't about living anymore.
It's about waiting for the next update.
The beauty of a number is that it lies.
It doesn't argue.
It doesn't explain.
It just is higher or lower, better or worse, success or ruin.
And by reducing your messy, beautiful, infuriating life to a single digit, you've done something
brilliant.
You've removed all risk of nuanced satisfaction.
No more gray areas.
No more maybe I'm happy.
Just this, the number went up.
Therefore, I am worthy.
Or, the number went down.
Therefore, I am trash.
And the worst part, you don't even realize you've done it.
You start small.
Maybe it's Bitcoin.
Maybe it's unread emails.
Maybe it's the engagement rate on your last post.
Something that updates in real time.
Something that demands your attention like a hungry ghost.
And then you begin the audit.
20 times a day.
Refresh.
Refresh again.
Because if the number hasn't moved, that means you're still alive.
And that's not enough.
Kahneman proved it.
The pain of losing $100 isn't just bad.
It's twice as bad as the joy of gaining it.
So you play the game.
A 10% gain.
Mild, suspicious satisfaction.
A 5% drop.
Existential collapse.
And if, by some miracle, the number spikes, don't celebrate, worry instead.
Because the universe has a cruel sense of humor.
The better things go, the harder they'll fall.
Regression to the mean isn't just a statistical concept.
It's a personal guarantee.
And that's how you become a human spreadsheet.
No more colors.
No more shades.
Just deltas.
Up or down.
Win or lose.
Asset or liability.
You've traded your humanity for the cold precision of a balance sheet.
And now you're not even a person anymore.
You're a number with a pulse.
Consider the empty inbox.
The subject in the residence log knew it well.
Every new email wasn't just a message.
It was a loss.
A betrayal of their hard-earned status.
Because in the world of metrics, even stillness is a kind of failure.
Give a man a fish, and he eats for a day.
Give a man a metric, and he worries for a lifetime.
And the worst part, he'll never stop checking.
Have a reaction.
Thank you.
I'll becase to the胸.
The mountains.
Down is a bad day.
Down is a great choice.
And the story takes place...
And some of the what matters is the matter.
That's good.
You're not a good.
You're not a good?
I can't talk to battery life.
Amen.
It's a good night.
The whole body has a brain burn.
It's like at gym here.
It's a good night.
It's okay.
And some of theอก sun begins.
Now it's good.
You're not a good night.
It's good.
You're not a good day.
It's all.
Yeah.
Too long it's out.